un prompteur un écran et des micros on
se croirait presque dans un vrai jt à
l'exception fait que les journalistes
ici sont en réalité des cm1 pour la
semaine de la presse et des médias à
l'école
sept classes de 25 élèves de l'école
primaire de bruit à réaliser son propre
jt pour l'heure webradios les élèves ont
l'habitude de faire des jt dernière
classe pour s'entraîner justement un tir
les choses à être convaincant voilà
c'est juste un vin de travail si en
interne qui qui prend en compte les
compétences qu'on doit être à faire
travailler à l'école le thème la liberté
d'expression et pour se prêter au jeu de
l'invité un journaliste venu parler de
son métier mais aussi le directeur
académique en personne c'était
extrêmement important d'une part de
montrer aux jeunes que on peut
s'exprimer comme vous le dites également
de leur apprendre à s'exprimer c'est à
dire de leur apprendre à dialoguer alors
apprendre à écouter l'autre de leur
apprendre à répondre à partir
d'arguments
du côté des journalistes en herbe tous
ont joué le jeu pour l'occasion qui nous
avait troqué ses habits des colliers
pour ceux de présentateur d'un jour
c'est un peu le chef c'est celui qui
prépare celui qui qui lance le sujet
qu'est ce qui t'a plu le plus bas de
lire le texte puis de pâlir juste lire
mais d'exprimer de de mettre le ton de
ralentir d'accélérer le temps n'est pas
précis quant à matisse et wayne et jules
ils étaient eux aux manettes en régie si
tu faire la transition entre parce que
donc nous on avait le conducteur mais
que pour le présentateur et le
journaliste ça a été difficile un peu de
savoir quand l'invité
finissez sa phrase et sinon c'est
relativement facile parce que c'est des
touchés on doit appuyer sur les touches
pour changer de caméra
la semaine de la presse à l'école c'est
jusqu'au 26 mars 2016 je vous souhaite
une très bonne journée et à bientôt sur
dru live